John how are you feeling how's morale
today pretty good I still haven't gotten
over 96 to be honest with you man what
bothers you about that World Series loss
how many we would have won in the next
five years the fact that everything
changed in our organization players
traded that's the one that's the one I
don't my therapist that I'm not supposed
to talk about it but do you know here we
are in the World Series if you had won
that World Series that everybody stays
together and you think you guys would
have gone on a run that the Yankees
ended up going on yeah exactly
you know 95 was such a relief and it's
still the only championship the city has
and you know bringing up the Falcons and
what they almost had last year but I
think that's the fate of sports you know
the Yankees spun on a four out of five
and good for them and they took
advantage of it I thought that's what we
could have done we had such a great
nucleus and and up to Oh coming home
those are the kind of things that you
you dream about but this is supposed to
be based on pitching you get to the
postseason and you guys had one of the
greatest staffs in the history of the
game and it still didn't work yeah yeah
and you look back you know just amazing
series that Houston and New York had and
how quickly it can spin you know how
quickly momentum changed you're talking
about
each team dominating in their own
ballpark and and turning it around on a
play at the plate or a defensive play
and that's what's so amazing about you
know you play 162 games but in a series
much like we watched it really can turn
that quickly and you never know and you
got to be prepared because you're
dealing with you're dealing with
storylines and you're dealing with
confidence that changes in a
best-of-seven series and the team that
can flex its muscles and take advantage
of it usually goes on to win Yankees
didn't advance because of they just
couldn't hit on the road I can't believe
it I mean I really can't believe how
well and how dominant
Houston became at home in a ballpark
that really is a hitter's ballpark three
runs in four games that that is that
something I could have never or anybody
could have ever seen you know when you
talk about again the Yankees offense
turning on a dime in game four down four
nothing and it just looked like they
were rolling and sometimes as you always
know in baseball you that the ill-timed
day off when you have won three in a row
came at the wrong time for New York the
Astros are here because they have a they
have a unique way of blending their
great offense with the top to starting
well you could say 3 when McCullers is
healthy starting rotation is is now
legitimate their pen has been a little
bit shaky and guys have come out of
their normal routine and shown a little
bit of nerves in the postseason but
their offense is so dangerous and it got
shut down in New York but it woke back
up they're just a really really good
baseball team that blends all the
learning lessons that they've had as an
organization look they were all in in a
lot of different analytical ways and
they made changes you can't go you can't
go from one of the worst baseball teams
and strikeouts to the best you know if
you're not if you're not with what
watching those things and and making no
changes and they did that and I think
since 1918 has there ever been a team
that's been in the bottom five and then
turned into the hardest team to strike
out the next year
Johnny Smoltz the hall-of-famer they got
game one World Series in Los Angeles
coming up Tuesday night coverage starts
at 7:30 Eastern on Fox all right if
you're the Astros your approach to
Clayton Kershaw in Game one is what
you know what's unique about that is
they don't really have anybody that's
faced them so their approach would be
Clayton's gonna have to kind of navigate
through the unknown and what better
person to do that being at home but I
think I would say the approach is you
continue to try and control the strike
zone and don't swing it's easier said
than done at that curveball slider they
hit the fastball better than most teams
in baseball so if they can confine you
know Clayton who's one of the best
control pitchers that we've got from
swinging outside the strike zone it's
going to be it's going to be a good game
for you know a good chance for the
Astros that's it just speaks to why they
don't strike out as much and what they
did in New York was uncharacteristic
expanded a strike zone
Yankees had their way with them in New
York best lineup best hitting lineup
Astros or Dodgers Astros okay the Astros
haven't shown it against Yankees but
they're the deepest lineup throughout
baseball that I've seen and and can
really make it hard to navigate Nava
Dodgers they've done it in ways that I
mean I don't know how many people could
have seen this with the injuries they've
had to be able to put up the homeruns
and the offense the numbers they've done
with guys that you know [ __ ] Hernandez
did not maybe have the best year
offensively all of a sudden boom paid up
playoffs timing is everything but you
also have Corey Seager's expected back
ease you could make the case he's their
best player you know so you yeah you
made it this far without him and that's
it that's a big addition to have you
know with what Turner Puig is playing
well you know Bellinger he's the
difference
yeah please the difference he's a
totally different player Corey Seager
maybe a little rust early but having him
back in the lineup makes that that
lineup so good and then of course when
you get unexpected dominance out of a
Corey
you know Cody Bellinger and you get you
get these kind of things look the
Dodgers are deep and we knew that coming
in their depth the payroll everything
that they put together was was primed
for this kind of run and as we said
earlier in the year there's so much
pressure on the Dodgers to get to the
World Series based on it
in almost 30 years so they did a great
job and they loaded up with better and
more I should say healthier starting
pitching to make that bullpen as good as
it is they needed the innings this year
out of the starters they got I know that
you played well pitched well in the
postseason but we're still trying to
understand you know the pressure that
Clayton Kershaw applies to himself
others will apply it to him as well he
hasn't had this this stage yet now he
has this stage but Maddux and Glavine
weren't great postseason pitchers but
they were Hall of Famers what is it
about this moment that brings out the
best and sometimes the worst in a
pitcher you know the focus on the
greatest pitcher in the game and and how
great Greg and and Tommy were there's an
emphasis on ok you got to continue you
maybe need to be greater and you don't
that that's the one thing that Clayton
ran into one team that kind of had his
number and everyone started going what's
going on and I maintained and I still
maintain if he's given the opportunity
just to get more starts you will see the
greatness come out in a poke in a
regular season nobody's more prepared
nobody has dominated baseball more and
no one has a greater expectation I call
it the Greg Maddux expectation you can't
keep topping the year before and they
did and that's the one thing about
Clayton where his every year he keeps
getting better and they expected at the
end you know to keep carrying the the
campaign of the season he pitched a lot
of games on three days rest he was asked
to do a lot the physical towles of
course the last two years have kind of
taken its toll so maybe you know just in
an in a in a weird way he's a little
fresher and doesn't have to feel like
the interesting thing for me will be and
it's always the tough part about the
manager what do they what kind of role
do they have based on if they're down of
Clayton Kershaw will he pitch on three
days rest this time once he gets to this
point and has you know generally been
given enough rest but Clayton's fine
they've won the last seven or eight of
his postseason
so they spine Maddox or Kershaw well you
know I'm biased I've never in my life
seen a guy go through a lineup with such
view pitches and dominate a game like
Greg Maddux I I just got to watch it
firsthand I got to see him carve people
up without i popping stuff clayton is
such a dominating and they're obviously
different left-handed and right-handed
is it is it is like you know Picasso on
this in his artistry I I never I don't
think we'll ever see anything like it
again based on the way he threw and and
based on the economy of which he got it
done so slight edge to Maddux of course
he did it for twenty years but if
Clayton could stay healthy you'll see
some things be rewritten but I also
think you know baseball cyclical I think
you're gonna have the guy who can throw
with the breaking ball movement it
that's coming back John because
everybody is thrown the same pitch
everybody's throwing 95 to 100 I think
you're gonna see more and more people
and this is what's great about Kershaw
he can get the 95-96 but that breaking
ball
Keuchel the same way the guys are able
to move the ball a little bit I think
that's the difference with a lot of
these great pitchers everybody's
throwing Heat it's can you do something
else with the ball that's my Maddox
today Maddox would be unbelievable today
and that's saying a whole lot
considering what he was yeah and you got
some people who disagree which I agree
with you you know people think if you
don't throw 95 you get killed today I
should listen the guys that are
successful the combination guys who and
and you you talk about with Kershaw the
guys who can hit their spot will expose
the hitter greater today than they ever
did before because the philosophies
changed on the bat true and the launch
angle changes so if you can carve up a
guy see a hitter today sits in a spot
doesn't change doesn't adjust and says
I'm banking that you can't make three
pitches to my weak spot
and as soon as you make a mistake I'm
putting in the seats
that's what baseball's become today and
I think to your point when you can have
the combination of command and stuff
there's no chance that those hitters are
going to have a greater success against
you have fun on Tuesday night will be
watching we'll catch up with you during
the World Series Johnny can't wait my
passion buckets almost empty it's been a
long road but there's gonna be a great
World Series hi but thank you tell Joe
we said Laurie that's a John Smoltz Fox
ends the World Series coverage begins at
7:30 Eastern coming up on Tuesday night
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]